ihr FDP Verkehrsminister Herr Wissing
will jetzt die letzte Generation am 2
mai offiziell treffen es geht ja nicht
darum mit ihnen zu reden im Sinne von
wie machen wir das gemeinsam sondern im
Gegenteil man muss man muss miteinander
vielleicht auch mal reden weil das geht
natürlich so nicht weiter also die
dieses tyrannisieren der Republik ist ja
keine Option reden was sagt man sie
wollen in die Ohren lang ziehen oder was
wollen Sie ja also man
kann aber vielleicht auch entlarven Herr
Lanz also die einzige Forderung der
letzten Generation ist das berühmte
Tempolimit ich habe manchmal den
Eindruck es geht dort eher um
Selbstdarstellung einzelner als dass es
wirklich um klima geht das sind für sie
alles Selbstdarsteller also ich kann
nicht erkennen als dass es den wirklich
ums Klima geht ich habe eher den
Eindruck es geht darum sich auch ein
Stück weit wichtig zu machen und zu
stören wenn es ihm wirklich ums Klima
gehen würde dann müssen wir über andere
Dinge reden mit denen beispielsweise
über die Frage wie missionshandel müssen
sie ja machen sie sitzen in der Politik
und die Leute die sitzen ja nicht den
Parlament